eu quero compartilhar duas práticas para
a gente tentar entender o que está
acontecendo dentro da gente para
melhorar a comunicação e claro a maneira
como a gente aprende a maneira como a
gente se educa
tá certo são duas coisas uma é fácil ea
outra é difícil eles querem começar por
qual pela difícil claro se não era 30
segundos só tá bom a difícil é a
seguinte é eu sou um dinossauro né da
televisão eu comecei a fazer televisão é
a 35 anos e esse veículo um veículo
surdo é um veículo que não houve
não ouvi as pessoas né é um veículo que
num não foi programado para ouvir ele
foi programado para emitir por isso que
a gente ainda chama as televisões e
emissoras de televisão
a grade de programação é um veículo que
nunca se importou muito em ouvir o
telespectador
então ao longo dos anos eu fui fazendo
programas né que tinham muito a ver com
essa aí génese da televisão e finalmente
eu fui cair nesse hospício chamado cqc é
que conheci di com a chegada da primeira
rede social relevante que foi o twitter
e que aconteceu algo incrível a gente
começou a usar essa rede desde o início
desse projeto então eu gosto de dizer
que o cqc é um programa nativo digital
numa época que essa palavra ainda não
era muito usada e acontece ao incrível
no ano seguinte à estréia do cqc que foi
esta matéria do wall street journal
dizendo o seguinte no brasil a
telefónica aposta nos tweets de uma
celebridade no caso era eo acerto
e quando a sony abraão chama de
celebridade acontece uma coisa mas
quando o the wall street jornal é foi um
tumulto na minha vida conheci receber
emails de várias procedências de vários
continentes tentando entender como que
eu estava usando o meu twitter e isso
fez eu começar a prestar atenção nos
tweets que eu recebia do meu
telespectador que tinha ficado calado
até então eu comecei a cuidar desses
tweets com muito carinho e já mostrei
eles várias vezes vou mostrar mais um
pouquinho pra vocês
olha que coisa inusitada um programa de
humor começa a ser recebido como um
programa de informação as pessoas
começam a ver discernimento começam a
ver uma análise dos fatos
no nosso programa de humor a gente não
sabia diz como eu fiquei sabendo
ouvindo o meu telespectador que eu nunca
tinha feito isso é uma coisa inédita na
minha vida e eu continuei ouvindo este
cara
esta é a prática que hoje a gente
precisa muito entender em profundidade
como nos ouvir na era do ruído
nessa era tão veloz eu tenho uma tarefa
grande pra ouvir porque eu tenho uma
rede muito extensa
desde lá né de lá pra cá cresceu muito a
minha rede de seguidores e as
ferramentas para ouvir também
elas foram evoluindo elas foram se
aperfeiçoando hoje eu consigo ver de
onde vêm os meus comentários que o
horário que esses caras falam comigo ou
seja hoje só não houve quem não quer
quem é preguiçoso quem está com com medo
talvez de ouvir o que a sua rede tem
para te dizer e eu continuo ouvindo
e eles me ajudam muito a saber quem eu
sou
qual é a comunicação que eu estou é
passando para quem está lá do outro lado
na outra tela então olha o tamanho da
encrenca gente olha a quantidade de
coisas que acontecem na internet um
minuto
a gente tem um volume gigantesco de
gente falando como ouvir como ver com
qualidade o que você está recebendo da
sua rede e mais do que isso
como descobrir o que você está
comunicando porque tem um mandamento
muito básico da comunicação que parece
óbvio mas que é difícil da ficha cair a
gente entender a comunicação não é o que
eu estou falando aqui é o que vocês
estão ouvindo vocês aqui nesse auditório
e vocês sabe lá onde vendo esse ted no
youtube comunicação não é o que estou
falando é o que vocês estão ouvindo eu
não tenho controle sobre o que vocês
estão vindo então vamos lá eu tenho uma
história para ajudar a gente entender
essa essa coisa complexa
os sete sábios cegos e o elefante era
uma vez um lugar na índia onde havia uma
região muito distante governada por um
rei muito eficiente todo mundo gostava
dele porque ele usava esses sete sábios
como oráculo qualquer problema que havia
ele consultava os cegos e eles
respondiam qualquer dúvida que o rei
tinha o sábio 70 uma espécie de google
do rei tá certo
um belo dia chegou um elefante um
elefante diferentão muito grande muito
fora das proporções dos elefantes
daquela região e eles começam a sentir
um medo daquela daquela novidade
o que será que representa elefante
prosperidade ou desgraças que estão a
caminho o rei chamou sete sábios
e cada um deles foi analisar aquela nova
realidade então um seguro no rabo e
falou para o rei é uma corda o outro
seguro na trompa em fá lo é uma cobra o
que segurou na cabeça falou é um
caldeirão o na barriga uma parede e
assim por diante e o rei percebeu que os
sábios estavam apenas interpretando uma
parte da realidade
todos eles estavam corretos na
interpretação e ao mesmo tempo todos
estavam sem o panorama geral do que
representava o elefante que era
realidade essa fábula pode nos ajudar
muito a entender como hoje a gente gasta
muito tempo na internet
debatendo interpretações da realidade
a gente gasta muita gasolina gente a
gastar muito ódio só disputando
interpretações na hora de discutir o
brasil que é o elefante
a gente fala das unhas das entranhas a
gente fala do rabo da cobra
mas a gente nunca fala quase sempre
nunca fala do panorama geral do nosso
país do brasil usam e aí que eu creio
que há algo muito legal da gente
entender o viés a interpretação da
realidade quando começou às
interpretações da realidade tem muito a
ver com as necessidades aí a gente está
vendo agora é coisas relacionadas à
agricultura
as interpretações ainda a gente está
vendo planetas
vemos aí agora os egípcios tentando
rastrear e consolidados de planetas
circulando lá no céu aqui copérnico fala
a terra não é o centro do universo e
quase roda por isso
e finalmente galileu galilei interpreta
algo muito importante o tempo
galileu observa o pêndulo né numa
a catedral e da interpretação dele surge
um relógio mecânico da observação dele
esse pêndulo o relógio mecânico érick
aliás é o relógio que vai nos ajudar em
toda revolução industrial que se seguem
e mapas para conseguirmos avançar nos
descobrimentos e finalmente um nome
muito importante
guttemberg é o cara que espalha tudo
isso é o cara que compartilha todo o
conhecimento e aqui vocês vão ver agora
a exponencial idade que rola nessa nesse
século 15
a primeira gráfica de guttemberg tá ali
no centro desse mapa onde a gente chama
de europa tá certo
olha o que acontece em um século apenas
neto em uma explosão de gráficas por
todo o território da europa e uma
experiência de idade na publicação de
livros no século 18 a gente atinge a
marca de um milhão de livros publicados
aqui outro fenômeno curioso que tenha a
ver com a nossa escala exponencial
os livros guttemberg não tem no início o
que está faltando ali no primeiro livro
gutenberg a página numerada e aí
finalmente alguém começa numerá índex a
informação ea gente começa a ver um
fenômeno curioso existimos cientistas em
lugares diferentes que estão estudando a
mesma coisa começa a trocar informação
assim o primeiro livro de medicina
algumas décadas depois olha qualidade
dos detalhes do estudo de anatomia como
evolui e não só na área da medicina área
da medicina começa a influenciar as
artes e isso gera uma explosão que a
gente chama de renascença
hoje nós temos a possibilidade de troca
de páginas numeradas só que numa escala
que eu vou avançar agora para a gente
entender qual é a nossa escala é uma
escala planetária que tem a ver com o
cara que fez o roteiro deste filme 2001
uma odisséia no espaço o arthur clarke o
claro que um cientista que escreve este
artigo
uma revista e inspira a invenção do
satélite
o satélite estréia em 1969 com essas
imagens e aqui eu gosto de dizer se dá o
início do tempo real que é o tempo onde
todos nós trabalhamos hoje
estudamos cuidamos dos filhos
vamos até viemos até de teatro para ver
essa palestra e já estamos combinando
que vamos fazer depois eu continuamos
respondendo e mails ou falando mal do
palestrante ou enfim o tempo real é o
tempo onde todas as instituições hoje
vivem e onde os negócios vivem e as
possibilidades de nove novos negócios
está localizada graças a esse senhor o
clark e curiosamente e não por acaso no
mesmo ano onde começam os satélites
existe a estreia da internet 69 é o ano
em que a arpanet circula pela arpanet 4
nós apenas a primeira mensagem enfim eu
estou fazendo esse passeio para
homenagear esse senhor aqui o clark e em
homenagem a ele
a área do que onde ficam satélite obras
já estacionaram foi batizada de cinturão
de clark e essa área hoje está assim e
tem essa outra área submarina em nove
milhões de cabos submarinos que conectam
esta rede então a nossa realidade
ela não tem volta
o que nós estamos criando juntos
é algo que só se acelera sócia
descentraliza essa é a tarefa que a
gente tem aceleração digital onde fica o
cidadão no meio disso tudo é a nossa
tarefa que eu vim aqui contar pra vocês
eu vou dar um exemplo é de como está
essa tarefa usando dois políticos um
político da era antes do digital e um
depois do digital
vamos ver como que mudou a tarefa da
comunicação e mais o controle sobre o
cidadão
os políticos conseguiam de uma certa
maneira consolidar a sua imagem junto
aos cidadãos
antes do digital e depois do digital nós
vamos ver o que aconteceu com ele tá bom
eu vou escolher um político que dominava
muito bem os veículos prede tais os
jornais as rádios e as televisões
eu vou falar de getúlio tá getúlio é um
cara excelente de rádio excelente de
mídia impressa e olha ele tinha até
instagram os cards do getúlio e se você
der um google no getúlio vargas você vai
ver o que eu tô falando cara olha esse
cara sabia controlar sua autoimagem tá
certo vamos pro político agora que ele
olhe aqui tá na fazenda dele no rio
grande do sul na amazônia
vejam como o figurino é até muito
parecido o controle sobre as pessoas que
estão em torno dele dos assuntos na
questão em torno dele
o cara era um craque vamos pro político
da era digital
tá bom tão preparados eu vou poupar
vocês eu não vou botar um político
brasileiro
eu vou colocar alguém está muito na moda
eu vou botar flademir rotina
putin também olha ele controla bem a sua
imagem ele é um cara bonitão ele sabe
sair bem na foto e ele gosta de tirar
foto sem camisa
só que tem um detalhe o putin é um cara
da era digital
então no ano de 2017 usaram esta imagem
do putim maquiado
é numa manifestação contra a homofobia
na rússia
ele deveria ter ficado orgulhoso porque
homofobia é crime na rússia não
putin é ele ele proibiu ele declarou
ilegal compartilhar a imagem dele
maquiado
o que vocês acham que aconteceu no
segundo seguinte né
aconteceu isso aconteceu isso aconteceu
isso aconteceu isso há uma palavra
fundamental que os políticos que os
governantes que os diretores de escola
que os prefeitos que os pais e os
educadores têm que aprender sobre o
digital transparência não é opcional
ela já vem no pacote não tem como de ter
uma opinião
principalmente quando você pisou na bola
principalmente quando você não tem
argumento é isso que a gente tem que
aprender com o senhor vladimir putin e
pra eu ir embora mesmo eu tenho uma
último dado do meu bloquinho para
compartilhar com vocês
essa senhora me pára na saída de uma
palestra que eu dei uma empresa de alta
tecnologia com uma lista de compras
dizendo o seguinte tas
esta é a lista de compras que o meu
filho thiaguinho no interior do espírito
santo pediu pra eu comprar sabendo que
ia passar uma semana que trabalhando em
são paulo
dá uma olhada na lista de compras do
thiago
quero convidar vocês haverá lista de
compras de thiaguinho 10 anos interior
do espírito santo
gta san andreas guitarra do ps2 medal of
honor resident evil 4 o ina levam dez ou
doze street 2 é de futebol americano
naruto smaq crônicos e por final o
marcelo tas
ela falou eu já tinha encontrado quase
tudo só faltava você eu falei pode levar
à pergunta que diferença que tem da
lista de compras do tiago 10 anos
interior do espírito santo
o thiago dez anos são paulo thiago 10
anos nova york berlim uberaba uberlândia
bedin hum eu eu quero muito entender os
seguintes
será que as instituições os governantes
as escolas às empresas os prestadores de
serviço estão preparados para atender os
thiaguinho se o thiago está no radar de
vocês como ouvir os thiaguinho se é um
desafio e é uma boa notícia também
porque o thiago estava fora do radar
agora cuidado quando for tratar esse
cara não subestime a inteligência dele
não vai tentar vender o helleva 9
ele que é o 10 já sabe que tenho 12
tá certo então fica esta dica ea minha
última dica eu falei que tinha uma
difícil uma fácil não é
é difícil é essa ouvir o cara que está
do outro lado
a fácil meus amigos para a gente
sobreviver na era digital e ter uma
excelente comunicação e nos atualizar o
tempo todo a gente só tem que fazer uma
coisa filhos fasam filhos
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]